hello and welcome to episode 5 of game
on I am your host Todd Kerpelman and
with me today krispy developer relations
Christy Uccello and we are here to talk
to you today about game controllers but
first we'll heat with some news and
updates from the Google Play game
services side of things first off we
have an official Stack Overflow tag so
yay if you've got questions about
achievements leaderboard cloud save
multiplayer any of that you can go to
stack overflow and find us under the
Google Play game services tag hopefully
by the time this video comes up this tag
will be available there they're working
on it and you can start asking us
questions there we've got we've got guys
much smarter than me that are monitoring
that tag and they answer a lot of your
questions so go there if you've got a
question about support amount of
specific platform you know pair it with
like an Android or an iOS tag and well
we'll try and answer your questions also
there is a great new feature on the Play
games developer console it's the
greatest feature that you've probably
overlooked because it's like this tiny
little link at the bottom but it's the
new get resources feature so you got to
check this out this is from our sample
game the hyper number challenge you'll
notice I've got six achievements here
and I've got a couple leaderboards and
in the past I had to kind of copy and
paste all of those random strings and
half the time when I clicked on
something to try and copy the string it
would take me into the details page and
was really annoying well now I can click
on this little link here at the bottom
and this will bring up a dialog box
where I have all the text I need ready
to copy and paste into my Android
application or my iOS application or my
JavaScript application and if none of
these code samples exactly matches the
way you're implementing your achievement
and leaderboard strings we also just
have plain old text version that you can
copy and paste and
through a python script or what have you
so for all of you that are implementing
you know 200 achievements all at once
this should be a really big time-saver
and we're really excited to have this
out there so check it out if you haven't
seen it yet it's a it's the greatest new
feature ever well maybe not ever but
it's close and so with that either way
let's get into game controllers on
Android and I'm gonna hand the clicker
off to Krispy hey thank you very much
everything um he's the expert I don't
know if I'm an expert yet I'm hoping to
become one and this is sort of that
first foray into that so I spent a lot
of time with game controllers working on
the stuff that I work on and I've had a
slew of them crossed my desk and you
know with that you know this is sort of
the first thing what does it mean to
support a game controller on Android
because there's so many different
devices and they all choose slightly
different ways of connecting to and ER
itself a lot of them are either
Bluetooth or USB those are typically the
only options that you're going to have
but one interesting thing is when you're
building an application that utilizes
game controllers you have to factor in
that you're taking the user's ability to
really touch a screen away from them and
this is a good thing and a bad thing
it's it's a good thing in that it gives
you that that tactile feedback when
you're manipulating the controls
pressing buttons etcetera it's something
that doesn't require you to focus your
attention on what you're touching you
can instead look somewhere else so this
is great for like Google TV Android TV
anything that is far away from you that
you can't really touch but on the
opposite side you can't really input
text that easily so if there's a lot of
input controls that would require
keyboard input that's not always there
so you know the plus points I'll just
summarize again physical feedback
sometimes haptic feedback with vibrators
negative side harder to input text and
there's a little bit more design work
that has to go into your UI but we're
going to cover some of more later on the
slides so let's talk about where the
api's came from in API level 12 we saw
the introduction of a lot of the
constants that were available for you
know dipping into game controllers
understanding whether an input device is
actually a joystick or whether has
joysticks whether it's a gamepad whether
it supports buttons and this has all
been available in the documentation
since API level 12 there's a link on the
slide right now if you're new to game
controllers this is the place to start
there's a summary section that really
details things like what to do with
source class joystick and search cost
buttons and game pads it's a good primer
it's not going to tell you everything
you need to do but it's a good place to
start to get ramped up on that material
now with API level 16 we saw even more
game controller support added and this
is where you can actually tap into
listening to connection and
disconnection events previous to API
level 16 you had to write your own
broadcast listeners to tap into when a
USB device was connected or disconnected
and you would also have to implement a
Bluetooth event listener that would tell
you whether the Bluetooth device had
connected or not you know you didn't
have it to write a lot of boilerplate
code for all these applications now with
API level 16 there's the input listener
that you can take advantage of and it's
it's definitely a big win so there's a
lot of support already there for game
controllers so the two places you're
going to want to look API level 12 the
link is on the screen and API level 16
check those end I noticed the the slide
here says something about querying
what's that
querying is polling what a polling of a
sort to find out what devices are
actually gamepads one of the things that
we'll talk about later on the slides is
how to identify an input device whether
it's a keyboard or a pointer or a stylus
or an actual gamepad and querying is
kind of an easy way of just getting the
subset of input devices that you care
about in that case we'll cover the
methods or some of the methods of
detecting input devices without using
the clear
no I don't want to go too much into that
okay yeah alright um so moving along
yeah
Oh scrolling the wrong thing there we go
so connecting controllers this is sort
of the first step in being able to use
them you know phones and tablets you're
typically going to rely on a Bluetooth
connection because it's really hard to
plug a fat USB port into your your Nexus
device I found anyway yeah but on you
know Android TV devices like Google TV
you can typically plug right into the
USB port and take advantage that and you
can leverage bluetooth so I think you
know I'm kind of recommending bluetooth
here but you shouldn't feel that you're
limited to only using bluetooth
especially if you want to target a
living room console style gameplay for
your users so just quick short facts
about where USB came from it was like
from 1994 there was a collaboration of a
bunch of companies that got involved and
they created the USB standard and that's
sort of evolved over the years to our
micro standard that we see now you're
not going to find any game controllers
that really connect with the micro USB
spec I haven't found any yet I'd be
interested if there were any but we'll
see I'll just mention to get API level
60 and introduced the ability to easily
search and listen for connected and
disconnected devices and actually before
I forget the button mappings when you
connect your game controllers but
mappings are a little weird if it's a
non or hid device sometimes you can
press the a button or the B button on
your remote or on your gamepad and it
will
is the back button so we'll talk about
how you can fix that a little later on
but just be aware that when you first
connect even though you can navigate the
the home launcher with it it might not
have the expected behavior right out of
the box so it's good for applications
maybe not so good for home screen
navigation okay so let's talk about
querying for game controllers this might
be a little small on the screen I say
that because even I'm having trouble
reading this slide now but I'll cover
the basics here what you want to do is
you want to take the input device class
and you're gonna ask it for you can
basically say get all device IDs and
you'll get back an integer array of all
the devices that are currently connected
to the Android system whether they're
virtual or real what you want to do then
is actually iterate over all those
device IDs and request again from the
input device class get device and you're
going to pass in the ID that you're
currently iterating on that will give
you an input device object and you can
now start to ask that input device
object about itself and the key here for
detecting game controllers is in fact to
use device get source so devices are
input device object that we created get
sources returns a an integer value which
is actually a set of bitmaps bitmask
mapped values that create a large
integer you will logically end those
with an input device source class
joystick effectively what you're doing
there is you're filtering out all the
other bits and you're just looking at
the one that's going to tell you hey
this is a joystick device or it's not
and if that returns non 0 then it is a
joystick device that means there's an
analog stick on it that is a joystick
axis from there you're going to want to
possibly check the the ranges that are
available for that joystick device so
we're gonna look at that now ok actually
sorry so going back so exercise so I
actually can't tell the device like are
you a gamepad I would
hey out of all the features that you
have do you have maybe a couple of
joysticks and some buttons and some
exactly you're gonna take the the get
sources and you're gonna ask it yes or
do you have the ability to provide me
joystick input you have the ability
provide me button input chances are if
it has a joystick
it's a gamepad yes is there anything
that would have a joystick that would
not be a gamepad I've done a lot of
tests would love it different input
devices I haven't come across any it's
it's entirely possible but probably not
a normal case what about like a stylus
then that would say I'm not a I'm not
new I stick guileless does have axes
based on the angle but it's not
classified as a game device it will
register itself that way gotcha okay so
with our joystick identified or the
device having a joystick we can go in
further and ask that joystick what
motion range is it has and this is
useful for determining the number of
axes that are available so if you had a
gamepad or or like some sort of game
input device that had two joysticks on
it it's gonna have a taxis right there
one for the vertical on each stick and
one for the horizontal and each stick
okay now if it also had analog triggers
on the left and right those will also
show up as axes but single axes so you
could have a device or maybe I did my
metaphor before for for the joysticks
don't ended up a wire for the trigger
for the triggers I was jumping ahead of
myself in my head that's okay so six
axes in that case and the the thing that
looks like a d-pad actually on game
input devices people think that it's a
digital input and it's not it's actually
a hat device with axes so you get
another two off of that so a d-pad looks
like basically it looks like a almost
like an analog joystick except that the
numbers aren't really analog right you
had a you know well it returns its axes
values as floats it'll either be 0 or 1
now don't get any the mil ranges whereas
the other more analog style inputs like
the triggers in the games joysticks will
return an analog value range between 0
or negative 1 + + 1 so that's just
something to be aware of so we we check
the motion ranges just to get a
principle idea of how many axes are
actually on this device and from there
we want to take that information when we
restore it in the state we want to
create a class that allows us to know
how many axes we have the IDS of those
axes and the values associated with them
so I'm just showing really the skeleton
of a state class here you're going to
want to extend that with things to
process the the axis input and normalize
it and all that stuff and we'll cover a
bit of that as we go forward but sort of
point out the critical things you want
to store number of axes the axes values
and you're going to want to use probably
a sparse array to store the number of
keys that you encounter the keys are
actually the buttons so these map as
keys I think it's a little weird but
buttons are keys okay correct me if I'm
wrong but the like in Xbox 360
controller for instance I believe those
buttons are actually analog is that is
that true and if I had something that
was similar is not I'm actually not
aware of that I didn't know get it I
could be totally wrong that's that's
what I vaguely remember manufacturers
can do different things and this just
goes back to what I said earlier there
is so many different types of game
controller inputs out there it's really
hard to know what they all are which is
why you know approaching the way Android
has approached it is really good lets
you query the device for what it's
capable of which lets you then determine
if the device is capable of providing
the right kind of input for your
application of game okay
so let's say a query device you know
it's a you know kind of standard to
analog joystick you know a couple of
triggers and it says okay you know I've
got these you know 6 analog axes how do
I know like which to for instance
correspond to the joystick on the left
so when you get a an on motion event and
we'll talk about some of the score
forward when you get a dispatch on
motion event from your activity class
that the event object is either a motion
event or key input event will ignore the
key input event so you get a motion
event and the event object itself has
information about what input source on
the device is providing that particular
input event so there's a couple of
things you can check whether it's a move
action associated with a particular axis
label so back to the the API as I
mentioned before API level 12 introduced
a whole bunch of constants that you can
use to determine which axes it actually
is on the device so they all map to
different constant values gotcha so for
instance if you know looking at a
controller the controller analog
controller on the left those two axes
generally correspond to constants like
what like move articles apart actual
access underscore lat X access
underscore Y now the one on the other
side of the controller if it's there is
typically labeled axes underscore R X or
X I'm my memory is a little fuzzy on
this but it's it's got my X's left axes
Y axes Rx and axis R Y basically right
but it's not always guaranteed to be
that way you might actually end up in
the case where that secondary joystick
axis is labeled with a Zed okay so ZX
said it's none of it is constant with
with game controllers and so you have to
do a bit of experimentation my advice is
to stick with you know some of the more
established brands because you're going
to get consistent behavior across them
more or less but it's a bit of trial and
error and you will probably end up
having to map a couple of different
types of controllers and adjust what
they're reporting their axes to be to be
consistent with your game logic mm-hmm
and the time to find that out is sort of
on my very first kind of get move event
from there yeah from that go ahead
exactly because you're not going to be
able to determine everything on initial
polling okay yeah but everything can be
dealt with on those events so one thing
I want to point out since we've talked
about the the state of the devices or
storing it you're going to want to
probably figure out an abstraction where
you know each player should be assigned
a controller device and let that be
consistent as well you want to let the
user
sort of whose control or whose
controller is mapping to which player so
one concept I have for this which I
haven't implemented yet but I would I've
seen in certain games is something along
these lines where you know the game
starts up and it's like alright which
players are assigned to which controller
so you'd have a list of all the gamepad
identified devices down one column and
all the players along the top and any
device can sort of push these bit or
these controller things into the right
player slot and then that player could
go ahead and configure their device to
their preferences so just something I
want to point out it's always a good
idea to allow if it's a multiplayer game
to allow the players to assign which
controllers are which otherwise they're
having to physically switch it it's it's
not experienced yet so now let's get
back to what we were talking about
before the handling of events so there's
there's two methods you're gonna want to
override in your activity and that is
dispatched generic motion event and
dispatch key event
my recommendation is whatever you're
going to write for your logic to manage
your input from a game controller you're
going to want to feed these motion
events from your activity into that
class don't try and deal with them
necessarily in the activity because
it'll just blow your code and it's not a
good way to abstract I think so whenever
there is a axis movement or a hat
movement or an analog trigger you're
gonna get the motion event so anything
that's analog will cause motion any
button event will trigger the dispatch
unit and this is where you want to start
to get into to filtering so you use the
constants again a look at API level 12
documentation on this to sort out which
which mappings are actually to the keys
you care about and I'm not going to
cover too much of it establishing how to
remap keys but allow the user to
reconfigure the layout of their device
another abstraction layer so you're
going to want to pass this off to
something that manages the device State
and then returns it back to whatever is
going to use that state
then modify the player controllable
objects in your application so it looks
something like this so your dispatch key
event you just matched your emotion
event coming to the activity you're
going to hand it off to through whatever
system to get the state back and use
that to power your application I want to
point out a few things about analog
joysticks you will have to be aware of
the dead zone
not all joysticks 0 or Center on 0 they
kind of they're moved around a lot the
mechanical things and so they can get a
little off and it can report to the
sensors luckily we have this thing
called the dead zone usually by calling
get flat on the the motion range this
allows you to determine some sort of air
tolerance when the the joystick is is
sort of released and not being touched
by the the player use the motion range
to of the joystick to determine the
stuff so the ones you care about or get
min get max and get flat which I just
mentioned you'll have to normalize your
access values accordingly so I actually
have a bit of code here that shows this
off the apartment so if we would have
process and axes and we have some access
value that we've gotten from our input
state or controller state object so we
have motion range we have the access
value what we want to do is we want to
get the absolute value of that access
value and then we want to determine the
dead zone so we're going to go get flat
and then we want to determine if the
absolute value is less than or equal to
the dead zone if it is return zero that
means that it's actually within that
range and we shouldn't do anything with
this or if the axis value is greater
than 0 we want to return the absolute
value divided by the minimum range which
gives us a normalized value if it's less
than 0 we're going to do absolute value
divided by maximum range so what I like
what do these numbers typically look
like like you know is get flat get so
I'm assuming Getman is a negative value
oh yes okay yeah so get men is a
typically negative one
okay and get Max's it's typically
followed one yes but you can actually
modify this if you want to actually get
out of let's say a method like this you
wanted to get some greater range you
want to expand it us you're not dealing
with with decimals you're instead
dealing with integers which is
completely possible you could add biases
to your calculations here to actually
spit out Oh a thousand or two hundred or
you know and get flat here would
probably look like say point zero five
or something like that oh I think it
would look even smaller it's like okay
it's usually like from what I've seen
from when I played this like point zero
two or zero two zero one it's it's very
small okay percentage because remember
the values we're dealing with here are
negative one to one and zero is supposed
to be that that absolute center but it
you know it fluctuates a tiny bit not a
great amount but if there's a lot of
wear and tear on the physical device you
might see greater values okay so one
more thing that I want to talk about
here is just about the user experience
when you're designing applications and
games that utilize you know digital
input and I'm gonna stay away from the
analogs for a minute because you're not
really getting navigate around that
let's say using the hat or d-pad don't
punish your users provide layouts that
are actually navigable and don't lead
them into traps so patterns that we
found useful are using shelves you might
remember this from or you might have
seen this in things like Netflix etc
where everything is stacked as a shelf
and you can just go along it allows you
to jump down or jump up to get out of
your current horizontal scroll because
you might have gotten a hundred units
over and you want to get back to some
menu item on the other side of the
screen if I go down and up or something
yeah that's your shortcut out as opposed
to having to scroll all the way back and
you know tabs can be utilized in this
fashion too to help a user jump between
a lot of content lists it's okay to use
lists but always provide the emp'd allow
the user to jump to the left or to the
right as appropriate and grid is always
good grid is is it maps from very well
2d pad
we find so one less thing I think I
mentioned it already allow the user to
remap the keys this is important some
people have preferences some people are
playing first-person shooters prefer the
inverted axes control which means down
as up and up as down those people are
crazy what do you prefer to use I know I
like oh it's that control I like up is
up to you know we're getting the about
you crazy and loud so yeah allow the
user to assign different controllers to
different players which we already
covered so at this point we're gonna do
demo so we'll just go to that now
alright so we chose Cordy to here I like
this game because it is very responsive
when using controllers I'd a lot of fun
playing it on the TV so on the first
screen here we've got an example of
using focus to your advantage so those
little white yeah if I move my gamepad
left and right it'll go back and forth
between by full game and choosing the
level so like this is a really good
example of how to illustrate visual
focus and this goes to what I was
talking about before when we were
talking about the layouts and how not to
trap the user etc so it's very important
to orient the user when they're
navigating with like an analog stick or
or d-pad or hat so we've got our little
game intro piece here Cordys coming out
all right so let's jump through the text
that comes up so this is all being done
with clicking on the button right you
got it you guys we're fullscreen so you
can't see me but listen these that these
are joystick noises I'm really actually
playing with a joystick so now you pad
yeah it just it feels very natural
almost like you're playing a console
really yeah I have to say this is uh
it's nice and smooth you'd actually
double jump in this uh-huh okay and you
know for me playing platformers like
this it's it just makes all the
difference to use a controller you're
not distracted by
on screen touch needs even though the UI
in this case is still showing some touch
commands you have the option to jump
back on touch screen which is great yeah
I have to say this is a lot more fun to
control using using a gamepad controller
it's a I don't have to kind of look to
see you know if my fingers are in the
right place I can kind of just feel that
and this just feels for me a lot more
natural playing a platformer game like
this absolutely and one thing that
actually frustrates me a little bit
about the on screen controller
simulators and that's kind of what I
call them is just simulation of game
pads sometimes when there's garbage
collection going on within the app or
even on the platform you can get some
you know some lanky feedback from what
you're touching and it actually caused
the game not to do what you intended it
to do I don't know if you've ever
experienced that I have not engine so
you know just makes for me anyway the
argument that all games really should
try and strive and support game
controllers in this way sounds good yeah
you know my only my only complaint here
is I'm sure this maps to a gamepad
button but I don't know which one is
yeah actually that's that's a good thing
to point out a lot of the on-screen
instructions in a game should if there
is controller support they should detect
that the input is mostly coming from a
controller and maybe adjust the
instructions to match the buttons so I
think there you go your figures it as
the B button yeah like that there we go
alright so yeah great game to play with
a controller there's lots out there a
lot of the controller vendors highlight
the apps that support their controllers
in the market and you should check it
out for some examples cool all right
well I could play this for the rest of
the video but I won't because we got
some wrapping up to do alright let's
let's get back into it alright alright
and so we've got a few some some Q&A at
the end I actually had a couple
questions that are not on here so I'm
getting oh yeah yeah let's do some
improv well so at the beginning you
mentioned you know you talked about sort
of there's two ways to
you know Bluetooth or USB does a
developer need to care like do I need to
know how my device is connected you know
if you're developing for Android
anything less than API level 16
you're gonna care because well Android
treats both USB and Bluetooth devices as
just input devices when it comes to
monitoring their connections and
disconnections which is something you
will have to do or anything lower than
API level 16 you're going to have to
right to broadcast listeners one for the
USB one for Bluetooth that's the that's
where the differentiation comes in
gotcha
okay so yeah if I'm if I'm planning you
know I've got a high-end game clearly
only modern devices might work moving
forward maybe I don't have to care if I
want to reach the broadest range of
customers as possible okay
now I've seen some game controllers or
gaming devices where you know the
essentially the controller is integrated
right into the device you know I've seen
a few of those myself
quite amazing how does how is that
represented and I guess do I need to
care about you barely they're
disconnected well it'd be hard to
disconnect a shield controller without
like breaking it you're probably right
if we think about other ones that are
similar form factor it all depends on
how it's connected if you're just
targeting one device I don't know how
likely a case that would be you're still
going to have to detect the input device
as being there so that's a good question
I'm not quite sure what the right answer
is there you get a you get a point for
that one all right I would say just like
treat it like you would any other device
don't assume that it's there you're
gonna try and build your application as
you said before for multiple devices and
and form factors don't make assumptions
okay so that would say fair enough
moving forward you know the world's
going wireless do you think bluetooth is
basically going to be the standard I
absolutely think so if we just think
about what it means to have wires and
I'm gonna go back to TV because
passionate about TV it really doesn't
make sense to have you know a really
long USB cable plugged into your TV or
your set-top box well you're sitting on
the couch people trip over it yes it
provides a very clean signal but it's at
the expense of being tethered so as we
in our lives move around more and care
about bringing our data with us and an
interoperability between devices
I think Bluetooth is only natural as as
the you know the de facto standard it's
not already is that going to be replaced
by a new and improved standard I don't
know I figured van when new I mean who
knows it could be the Internet is
everywhere and just powers things okay
let's see and then so speaking of sort
of you know modern game you know game
controllers has been sort of some
certainly in the news a lot about
Android powered gaming devices you know
I'm thinking like the Ouya and the
shield and and you know probably more in
the future
if I'm a game developer what is there
anything I need to know specifically
about sort of developing for kind of
this new generation of Android powered
game game devices or can I just sort of
address them like normal controllers I'm
gonna answer it this way that first
piece of advice do not lock yourself
into any vendors ap ice okay that is a
good way to shoot yourself in the foot
now there are reasons to do that if you
have deals with with a particular device
but it means you're going to limit
yourself to just that device a lot of
these Android game consoles all share a
lot of similar characteristics okay
they're usually boxes they're usually
boxes connected to televisions and they
usually have wireless controllers and
they all kind of have four buttons the
the right-hand and they have an analog
stick available on the left hand some of
them have the second analog stick and
they usually have triggers so if you've
ever played with you know any one of the
popular consoles out there and you kind
of all like the same yeah
that said what those keys map to for
that device
it could be different so I would say see
if you can take a controller from one
device and connect it to another one and
see if it actually gives you what you
expect back on like what the axes names
are and what the buttons are when those
events come in all right
and finally if I'm thinking looking at
all this and thinking boy this sounds
like a lot of work maybe there's a game
engine that can do it all for me what
there are game engines I'm partial to a
few myself I mean I haven't played with
unity that much but I hear good things
and I've seen it around libgdx is one of
my favorites and it does come with game
controller support it's an open-source
project I've played with J monkey engine
which is also pretty good if we were to
think about web games just for a second
I don't know it's a little weird to
mention it but if you if you load a web
page on your Android device and you try
and use a game controller none of that
ever works I don't I've never tried
doing that so there's no good engines is
what I'm Tracy and I've seen that
support game controllers on a browser
but it's it seems like most modern game
engines these days will have some type
of controller support absolutely it's
sort of essential for a game engine to
provide game controller support so if
you're choosing one and it doesn't maybe
you want a question using that write
them an angry letter or you know what
better yet if it's an open source
project fix the problem submit the code
patch it make the Internet and world a
better place it's much better than an
angry letter
there's too many angry letters in the
world that is true I get them all right
well I think that just about wraps it up
let me see do we have anything else in
our slides I think that's more and more
there oh right so yeah I guess we'll
point out here I'm in the process of
writing a series of blog posts I'm
targeting about five different posts
right now that really go in depth
technically on all the stuff that we
talked about today and a little
or around the UX guidance so keep an eye
out for those there should be a in the
near future where where would I find
these blog post eyes you would find them
on on the Android developers blog okay I
sometimes read that I read that
regularly alright I'm a fan all right so
people just keep an eye out there and
they'll see your blog posts in the next
next week or two I don't know if it's
gonna be the next week or two I want to
make sure all the details are nailed
down solid I don't wanna give anybody
bad advice
alright very very soon try I'm trying to
hold you to deadlines I don't give you
can't estimate things like that alright
so by the time this video is out all
five blog posts will be published and
not be perfect so sounds good ready
you're ready here first thanks Doug all
right well cool thank you very much for
for joining us Internet audience and
thank you crispy for pleasure for
providing some really excellent content
this week thanks and we will see you
guys in a couple weeks bye